so i will give you a very brief overview
of the five uh nice papers that would uh
appear in this session
uh and we will then hear a short talk
about each paper uh the top will be 10
one hour long we have some time in the
end uh
in that case i will open the floor for
questions about any paper in this
session
all right um so let me give you a very
quick overview of the papers in this
session so uh three of the papers in
this session uh study mechanism design
success that are not classical so these
include the first maximizing revenue in
the presence of theories the third paper
curse yes satisfy agents and the force
paper mechanism design was moral bidders
and then uh we have a paper uh that uses
new technology to help mechanism design
uh in particular they show how to use
cryptography to circumvent and
possibility result from mechanism design
so that will be the second paper of the
session
and last but not
least but not leave
our final talk will be about clock
auctions
which have many appealing properties
that make them popular in practice
despite its practical importance i think
these auctions perhaps have not received
enough attention from the theoretical
theoretical side
so i think the paper in our session
significantly advances our theoretical
understanding of these cloud auctions
so these are the five papers that uh you
know we will
hear on this
session
so without further ado uh let me uh
welcome our first speaker
or andrus
to talk about the
paper maximizing revenue in the presence
of intermediaries enters you can share
your screen and start your talk
perfect please let me know if can you
can you see the screen
yes
great
thanks so much thanks so much yang so my
name is andres pelrod and today i'm
presenting the paper maximizing revenue
in the presence of intermediaries
this is a junk world with jagan agarwal
shipra bawakar and kuru guru ganesh we
are part of the market algorithm teams
at google research
and to motivate the question we study
a common feature that we observe when we
are designing auctions is that most of
the time we assume that the buyers that
are interested in buying the goods in
the auctions
are the one actually building the
auctions
however there are many markets in which
this is not the case
there are intermediaries who are
representing those buyers and those
instrumentaries are the one building in
the auction
for example
in the ad auction world an advertiser
who wants to purchase an impression from
a publisher
is represented by chain of
intermediation that agency the dsp the
demand side platform who
are the one bidding on behalf of the
advertiser in that exchange
so the question is
what could change in auction design when
we incorporate those intermediaries
to motivate this consider the following
example where there is this seller who
owns these cheeses and there are these
buyers these mouses that each mouse
wants to buy one of the cheeses
we give a simple example suppose the
seller does a truthful auction
so in that case
let's say that the two highest led to
the
top
buyers are the one getting the cheeses
and now let's go stream and assume that
all the buyers are represented by the
same terminal area
well in contrast to the case without
intimidation in which the third high
evaluation buyer the one who did not get
the cheese is setting the price for the
chases
when there's intermediary the engineer
is going to only gonna sue me two beats
and therefore there's not gonna be a
price
i that is gonna be setting the cheeses
and therefore drone is gonna be very low
if the same buyers are gonna get the the
auction they are gonna receive the
cheese but the price is to be very low
and the intuition is that
the intermediary allows the buyers he or
she represents to collude and therefore
decrease the price pressure in the final
auction
in another example
consider the following more complex
demand structure in which the two high
valuation buyers are represented by the
same intermediary but the third one is
bidding directly in the auction
but importantly the insulator is now
charging a markup fee
as a broker whenever he trades on behalf
of the buyer he is gonna charge a
particular fee
for the good he buys
then the issue is that the final bit of
each of the buyers that are represented
by intermediary cannot cannot be very
high to get the cheese since the surplus
he he or she obtained had to have to be
split up with intimidated due to the
markup fee
so it may happen that let's say the
second highest valuation mouse the one
in the middle his beat when he was
bidding directly was winning the auction
but now due to the america fee is going
to be low enough so therefore the third
highest volume buyer is going to get the
the item the cheese but the second the
second one will not and therefore
revenue will also decrease
so what we observe here is that due to
the intermediary what we call an
economics double marginalization effect
the fact of market fees are decreasing
their trade decreasing revenue and
creating misallocation of the goods
so
what we see from the previous example is
that the mechanism and also the revenue
optimum mechanism will depend on the
downstream market between the buyers and
intermediaries how those buyers
relations are are connected with
intermediaries and how those
intermediaries what are the incentives
of the intermediaries to beat in the
final auction
so the question is what to do
so
if you would know exactly the demand
structure exactly the incentives of the
intermediaries which is we call the
downstream market if you know exactly
that then you can implement using
young's seminal paper with co-authors
you can use a similar algorithm to
actually obtain the optimal mechanism
however most of the time this option
mechanism will be very complex and
furthermore and very important for our
purpose it's going to be very sensitive
to the downstream market that is if you
believe a particular downstream market
structure and you implement the optimal
mechanism for that downstream market
structure
but you're wrong
then the optimal mechanisms can be
impacted by a lot
and revenue can consider it can can be
can decrease a lot
so what we do in this paper is to design
simple mechanism that will have good
revenue guarantees and furthermore are
gonna be robust to the downstream market
that is to the demand structure
how buyers are partitioned across
engineers
and also
to a wide variety of possible contracts
between intermediaries and buyers
so let me present an overview of the
model we first start with one seller who
owns k identical items we later extend
our model for heterogeneous items
there's n unit demand buyers with
valuations iid
according to the according to evolution
f
and there's these m intermediaries
and the way we model the demand
structure
first we assume that each intermediary
represents pile buyers where pi is a
partitional of the set of buyers
so therefore the partition represents
how the the demand structure
and regarding incentives we have a
general model in the paper but it
considers the most standard cases that
have been studied in the literature
first the case that an intermediaries
incentive is to maximize the aggregated
value the surplus of the buyers he or
she represents
or the second
or the second model which is that the
engineers wants to be profit maximizers
they're buying from the seller and
selling to the buyers they represent and
they want to maximize the overall
profits we have in our model incorporate
these two
important situations
the main assumption we you assume in the
paper is we we call that lambda
regularity we're going to be assumed
that f is lambda regular with parameter
lambda is really strictly less than one
it has a very similar feature to the
myersonian regularity but the first term
in the virtual evaluation is multiplied
by factor lambda
so we're going to be assuming that with
this strictly we're going to be assuming
that this lambda virtual evaluation is
monotone
every lambda regular is regular so this
is a strict subset of regularity
and the nice thing is that lambda
graphic has nice properties we show in
the paper that the maximum of
an id lambda regulation the regular
and the probability that the value
exceeds expected value is a constant
factor that only depends on lambda this
was previously shown by schreizer and
search on 2019
so
with that in mind the objective of the
paper is to develop what we call an
intermediary proof mechanism that is a
mechanism such that for any demand
structure any distribution f the
performance of the revenue
in the revenue of that mechanism will be
a constant factor of the optimal
mechanism we would obtain had we have
known exactly the demand structure and
the bios and the intimidation incentive
in the market
as we said before this optimal mechanism
would can be very hard but the key
observation that we use is that we use
we compete against welfare that is the
value of the market which is the value
of allocating the goods to the k highest
valuation buyers and the nice property
of the welfare is that although it's a
higher benchmark it is independent of
the demand structures and therefore we
remove the complexity of the revenue
optimum mechanism for a solution
so
here note that the lambda regularity is
very important because for regular
distribution for instance the hr the
equal revenue distribution welfare is
infinity so therefore using welfare as a
benchmark would be very hard to compete
impossible to be honest
therefore
now with lamb regularity let me
introduce you our a our ip mechanism the
intermediary improve mechanism so let me
give you an intuition of the mechanism
so the idea is the following we have end
buyers k goods we're gonna split
bios a group of size s and we're going
to target the highest value highest
valuation buyer of each group of each
group i'm going to set that price which
is the expected value of the maximum of
s
of s buyers
and we're going to set that expected
value as the price per item so our
mechanism is simply setting a price per
item equal to that expected value and in
case of excess demand we're gonna simply
randomly allocate the goods
among the interested buyers interested
bidders
so the main the first theorem we show is
that if you use this simple positive
price mechanism you're gonna be a
constant factor of the welfare
and let me give you a brief overview of
the constant factor
the one-half that we see
actually comes because nd by k may not
be an integer we believe that this can
be easily improved
c lambda appears twice this constant
factor is really the first
to bound the probability that the
highest value buyer in the group of sas
a of size s will exist the price which
is the expected value so that's why you
see lambda appears once the second lamp
time that zealand appears is because we
bound the probability that trade will
happen due to potential
markup fees due to double margin due to
the profit maximizer incentives of the
of the intermediaries so we we bound the
priority of trade by siland again
and the third term which is one minus
one over e
comes from the fact that
we are restricting ourselves in terms of
value to allocate to a to groups of size
s the goods one item for each group of
size s
and our benchmarks to allocate to the
highest without this restriction so the
one minus one over e
is capturing the destruction of
allocating two groups high of size s
compared to the welfare which is
allocated to the k highest valuation
buyers
so to finish let me briefly
introduce you our extension we're going
to be assuming that goods are
heterogeneous each good has a weight eta
eye and by buyer's valuations are
separable has evaluation vi multiplied
by the weight of the good
and here we're gonna use again the
welfare as a benchmark but the key
challenge is now that the highest
evolution buyer has to get the
better good with higher eta with higher
weight and so long so to for this
challenge we need to tune up our
research our pricing mechanism and we
use a pricing technique similar to what
we use in a gsp
so we use the pricing that depends on
the weights and if you use this pricing
actually again you are a constant factor
of the welfare if the intermediaries
incentives are actually to be surplus
maximizer the challenge for this case is
to show the probability of straight is a
constant factor which is this one minus
exponential
and to solve this challenge in the
pebble in the paper we develop a complex
program and using a
dual convex duality techniques we are
able to bound the probability of trade
by this one minus exponential
so without in mind and given the time
constraint i will finish thanks so much
and happy to answer questions
so
uh mariam uh you're the second speaker
right so could you share your screen and
um
i think for the interest of time maybe
we should save the question to the end
yep go ahead
so my name is miriam i'm a phd student
at princeton university and i'm going to
present work on credible strategy foods
optimal and found expected round single
item options for all distributions
and this is joint mark bandwidth
methodology i'm my advisor matt weinberg
so online auctions play an important
part in many internet applications such
as ebay in particular the biggest
revenue source of a lot of companies is
from online advertisement
and so reasoning about which auctions
are best to use is very relevant
in the early days of online
advertisement first price auctions were
the predominant mechanism and the way
first price auctions work is the high of
the bidders are going to place bids the
highest bidder wins the item and pays
their bid
however people didn't like first price
auctions because they were not strategy
proof for bidders so bidders were not
incentivized to big true value
and this created inefficiencies and loss
of revenue
and because of this limitation of first
price options the
second price options became popular in
second price auctions the highest fader
wins the item but pays the second
highest bid
and
as an example here we have alice placing
a bit of 80 bob plays in a bit of 20.
uh alice wins the item and pays 20
and second price auctions unlike first
price options are strategy pool for
bidders so bidders are incentivized to
get their true value
however they are not strategy proof for
the seller
uh as an example
um looking at the previous example here
there's nothing stopping the seller from
telling alice that the second high speed
is 79
i'm just talking in the 59 dollar
difference
and so it's not strategy for the the
seller
traditional auctions assumed that the
cell was honest but it turns out that
the sour isn't always honest
uh as we just saw in this example here
and so the second price auction is not
strategy for the seller
uh
so in the example we just saw the seller
has incentive to cheat and so we want to
ask the following question are there
revenue optimal auctions that are also
strategical for the seller and we're
going to call this property credibility
and we want to make sure that the
auctions we consider prevent any
cheating from both the seller and the
bidders
so we want the auctions to be both
credible meaning that the seller does
not cheat and truthful meaning that the
bidders
submit their true bid and revenue
maximizing so we want auctions to be
optimal
credible and truthful
and this leads us to our motivating
question here which is is there a
credible truthful and optimal auction
and this was already answered in
previous work where uh it was shown that
the ascendant price auction is the
unique auction that is credible truthful
and optimal
but it can require a number of rounds
that is unbounded and here the number of
rounds or the communication complexity
is defined as the expected maximum
number of times
that any bidder communicates with the
seller
and because of this this is going to
lead us to a more specific motivating
question which is is there a credible
truthful and optimal auction that is
that requires a constant number of
rounds
this was also answered in previous work
where
the
uh where they introduced the deferred
revelation auction but the third
revelation auction is optimal it is
truthful it is credible and it is only
two rounds and the way they were able to
get two rounds is because they use
cryptographic commitments
and
the use of cryptographic commitments
allowed the
so remember we saw that the ascendant
price auction was the unique auction
that was truthful optimal
and uh credible but it required an
unknown number of rounds here the
deferred revelation auction is also only
two rounds
and this is due to the existence of
cryptographic secure commitment schemes
so finally this leads us to
oh
um
and the deferred revelation auction the
way it works is that it's a modification
of the second price auction initially
the auctioneer requests all bidders to
cryptographically commit to their bid
and submit a deposit and then later the
seller is going to request all bidders
to reveal their bids and so if any
bidder refuses to reveal their bid their
deposit is forfeit and that deposit is
paid to the winner
and this uh works uh because it removes
the incentive for people for to make
fake bids because every time somebody
submits a fake bid they have to pay this
deposit that they lose
the problem with the dra is that it
didn't extend to
valuations that were
even drawn from regular distributions
and so this leads us to our main
question here
which is is there credible truthful and
optimal auction that is constant rounds
and that works on all distributions
and the answer to this question is going
to lead us to the main result of our
paper where we're going to introduce a
new single item auction that is credible
truthful optimal that ends in constant
realms and expectation and that works
for all distributions
before i introduce the auction i'm going
to quickly go over the model
so we have uh
we have a single individual item for
sale we have embedded with private
values independently drawn id from some
distribution d that is known to the
seller the bidders have positive linear
utility meaning their utility is just
their value minus whatever payments they
make and the question we're trying to
answer is there is is there a credible
truthful and optimal auction
that is constant rounds and that works
for all distributions
and we're going to propose our work is
going to propose the ascending deferred
revolution auction
which extends the dra results to all
distributions and has constant
communication complexity
and the way this works is recall in dra
the bidders are required to submit a
deposit at the beginning that they lose
if they try to cheat and adra will make
the deposit dynamic so we're going to
have multiple rounds and in h1 the
deposit is going to be slowly increasing
and our main result is going to be under
the existence of cryptographic
commitments when bidders are drawn our
id from some distribution d there is a
credible truthful and optimal auction
with constant communication complexity
that works for all distributions
uh i'm gonna try to go quickly uh over
the mechanism so the way the mechanism
works is that initially any bitter eye
is going to send a cryptographic
commitment ci to some big bi without
revealing any further information about
their bid
uh
two the auction is going to proceed in
rounds and to ensure that no bidder lies
each bidder is required to the positive
quantity f q that is forfeit if they lie
here f is any increasing function
uh in each round the auctioneer is going
to ask each remaining letter if they
should increase their bid
to their their bit to f of q
and their deposit also increases to
average q
if two or more bidders raise their bid
the auction proceeds to the next round
and then we ask the bidders to go to f
of f of q and so on and then if there
are if there's two if there's one better
left or less than one better left the
auction ends the auctioneer asks all
theirs to reveal their bid any bidder
that refuses to reveal their bid get
deposited back the auctioneer is going
to forward the review of bids to all the
other bidders
then they award the item to the winner
and the winner uh pays the second
highest bid
these uh these deposits have this
positive externality of removing any
incentive for the seller to cheat
and so the seller is going to face a
trade-off they can either can make
commit fake bids that they selected
selectively reveal but they are going to
pay a deposit that is um
for every bid that they choose to
conceal and as a result cra is credible
it also has good communication
complexity because when we can make it
so the function f for each round is
a direct function of the distribution
and
the way we got to adra is uh we were we
did a mix of the ascending parts auction
and
the third revelation auction so if you
compare adr to the ascending parts
auction you'll proceed in a similar
fashion and each round if a bidder is
still in the option the auctioneer is
going to ask them if they wish to
increase their bid the difference
however is that here we use some
function f that can be any increasing
function
and if you compare adra to dra you can
see that it's similar because all the
bears are required to commit to their
bid and submit a deposit the difference
here is that the deposits are dynamic
and they increase the longer a bit of
stays in the option
and
the main takeaway is that
the ascendant deferred revelation
auction or adra is optimal so it
maximizes revenue
it is truthful meaning that the bidders
are
uh incentivized to bid their true value
it is credible meaning that the seller
has no incentive to cheat it is constant
communication complexity and expectation
and this will and it holds for all
distributions uh regular irregular
and so our main result is this
uh adr we introduced a new single item
option adra that is credible truthful
optimal terminates in constant rounds
and works for all distributions we have
other results that i talked about in the
long talk that i've got
here
and some potential interesting next
steps would be to work on reducing the
deposit
um
or to try to extend this to be on the
iid framework so for example for bidders
that are independently drawn from
different distributions
thank you maryam uh i think we'll have
time for one question
so marion have yeah uh
i really have a question just to speak
up
yeah hi miriam uh that was a great talk
so
what does the
round complexity depend on
like or what is the constant
uh oh well it's no that the
communication complexity depends on the
function f that we use and so it can
like where you can make the f be
anything you want it to be we have a way
of making f of the function of the
distribution of the values are drawn
from and when we make sure that a
function of the revenue like the optimal
revenue it's a function of the revenue
basically and when we make it as a
function of the revenue we're able to
get a constant number of rounds
so it's a function of like the
distributions right like uh yeah
but it can be anything like um more
generally
thank you very cool
okay great so uh
gingko will be our next speaker
okay
uh hello everyone
um i'm jinta wong i'm very glad to
introduce our work kirstie is set by
agents this is a joint work with along
and edington
so in this work we consider the wings
course phenomena observed in the
interdependent valuation options
so in these options the value of the
item to agent depends on the preference
signals of all agents
and in this case the winner often
behaviorally overestimates the value of
the item and pays more than it was
finally leading to an active utility and
this phenomena has been observed in real
world auctions and in this paper we want
to mitigate the win occurs
so to understand the winner's curse
let's first consider a toy example
called the wallet game in this game
alice and bob beat up a wallet
containing the pocket mummy from both of
them
suppose alice has x and bob has y then
the wallet contains x plus y so the
auction value is jointly determined by
both of them and they each know the
exact amount of money of their own but
not the others but they know that each
one has a pocket money drawn from 0 to
100. now suppose bob has 30 dollars and
in a transfer mechanism actually about
bit so intuitively the as the
expectation of alice money is 50 dollar
so bob should be 80. but
if alice adopts a symmetric strategy
then bob only wins when he has more
money than alice so conditioned on the
event
that bob is winning
um
and the actual value of the item is uh
actually smaller
than
uh uh than the 80s so which will lead to
an
active utility for bob so bob actually
over beats the item
so in this work we explore the problem
of addressing the witness course through
the mechanism design perspective and
through a theoretical perspective
we ask that can we design good auction
mechanisms to elim eliminate winner's
curse and in particular we do not want
the winners to have negative utility so
this problem has two parts first how do
we model the bidder's behavior that
suffer the winner's curse and the second
how do we design the mechanism
based on the behavioral model
for the first problem we adopt the
similar work of estimate at the robbing
that captures
the
windows curse so the model is called the
cursed equilibrium model and the second
problem is the focus of our paper and we
will focus on the direct and
deterministic mechanisms
and our result to the mechanism design
problem is that we can't have such
mechanisms eliminating the winner's
curse but the sitter may need to
compensate the bidders
and then we further provide social wifi
and
revenue optimal mechanisms
and in this talk we'll focus on the
social welfare maximization
and in the following i will introduce
our option setting first and then the
behavioral model and finally the
mechanism design results
for the auction setting we consider a
single item with
a symmetric auction setting with
embedders each agent has a practice
signal si ranging from
zero to one
and the valuation function of each agent
could be different
but they should be symmetric
and also it depends on all the signals
and we focus on the direct auction
mechanisms so each agent
beats bi to represent its signal si and
the mechanism consists of allocation
rule x and payment rule pm
now
so we will introduce our behavioral
model for the crystal agents
so
that in the aston and the romance mode
an agent suffering the windscreens
can actually do the equilibrium
reasoning correctly just as in our body
game suppose bob suppose the validation
of the wallet is 80 then bob actually
did truthfully and originally but what's
the problem of bob is that
and he actually neglects the contingency
between other agent speed and their
signals in their belief when calculating
their
expected utilities so in this model
in this current equilibrium model a
fully rational agent will calculate the
joint distribution of other speeds and
signals correctly using the
basis room
but
for encouraged agents it will consider
the signals others other signals and
other speeds as independent conditional
its own signal and there is a kickr
agent which is modeled as an
agent between these two extreme case
and then the
result of this model is that in auctions
it turns out that and cursed agent will
play equivalently to a fully rational
agent with a correctly belief but with a
modified valuation function via key
which
is a combination of the correct
evaluation
and plus
and the merging
marginalized expectation value of the
item and here is a parameter to
representing the degree of the christmas
so now we are going to discuss our
mechanism design problem so we want the
mechanism to be exposed incentive
compatible and individual rational for
the curse agent
so these two conditions are symbols the
corresponding conditions for the fully
rational agent
but we just need to replace the original
expected utility function to the cursor
expected the utility function reality
you'll the
cursor valuation instead of the correct
valuation index and we also want to
eliminate the winner's curse so we also
want the real
individual
rationality
and the condition is here
where we use the actual
correct validation of the agent instead
of the curse valuation
and applying the mason's dilemma we get
our first result which is a complete
characterization of all the mechanisms
certifying these affirmations three
properties and the result is that the
allocation rule is any monotonic
allocation rule and the payment follows
the payment identity and because we
consider the deterministic mechanism so
the
allocation rule is actually our
threshold allocation rule
and the difference
from the
traditional masons uh auction is about
this constant term so in order to remove
the windows curse this constant should
have satisfies this condition so which
means that the constant
so no more than the worst case negative
utility introduced by winning the
auction and this worst negative utility
just happens when the agent's signal is
right at the threshold signal of the
allocation rule
um and this
works when the threshold is smaller than
one which means there's a possibility
that we will allocate that item so if we
reach this threshold to above one which
is the upper bound of the signals then
that means we will never allocate the
item to that agent no matter what the
signal is and
when
when this happens we could also set the
constant 10 and 0 as zero
so because this term is negative so that
means um on a certain threshold
allocation rule when the seller need to
compensate the
um bidders uh even if it loses a loose
law auction so a natural question to ask
is that how bad the composition can be
and can we do a good balance of the
compensation and other aspects of the
mechanism so we first have an
impossibility result here that is the
very common
um auction case if we want to achieve
the full efficiency then the required
compensation can glow super linearly to
the number of bidders which will expose
the budget
so we consider how much social welfare
we can achieve if we want to maintain
the exposed budget balance for the
sellers
which means that
after auction is resolved the total
payment of the agents is non-negative
and which fortunately we found that
under some mild conditions about the
valuation function and the crisisness
the social welfare optimal mechanism
under this exposed by the balance
condition is simple it is a masked
version of the general last bigquery
auction allocation rule plus the
previous payment identity function which
is proposed and this will give us the
social welfare optimal exposed by the
balance and here the mask
mask means that when a signal profile
um
under a certain threshold allocation
rule will possibly introduce induce the
winners curse then we just need to
risk the threshold to above 1 and to
withhold the item and do not allocate so
that's the means of the masking here
and then
the
next natural question is
what's this optimal social wi-fi look
like and we prove that if the federal
action function certified it belongs to
a family called concave sum functions
then
we can achieve approximately half of the
full efficiency when the number of
repeaters is
a large
and let's finally come back to our
rolling kit what this actual mechanism
look like so this mechanism will
allocate
the item to
the agent was how big only when the
other beats the other speed also exceeds
50 so
um
or which
and the intelligent behind that is if we
want to eliminate windscreens without
composition then we have to allocate the
item only when the majority of the
bidders have high signals about
the auction item
so
that's basically the result of our work
okay
thank you
uh i think we have time for a quick
question
okay
uh so jing tao so um
you're using
so much
free in the resort but
so can you say a few words about where
cemeteries is
hey uh okay here
uh yeah could you uh repeat your
questions sorry
yeah so uh
so you're you're in the symmetric
setting right
yeah yeah
yeah so can you say a few words about
you know where symmetry is used in the
result
uh
yeah so
this symmetry is uh used in
uh
uh yeah is uh for the first theory it
will use the symmetric to to to get this
uh worst case negative utility uh
introduced by by winning the
oh sorry so it it will be used in our
characterization about uh all the space
of the
uh
uh
the the mechanism that satisfy these uh
three properties the incentive
compatibility as well as the
uh
uh individual rationality so yeah
okay um
let's see
all right so i
actually have a follow-up question but i
guess for the interest time uh
um we should move on to the next talk uh
yeah so
uh could you share the screen
yeah thank you
and i want to tell you today about the
mechanism design with malpitas
so many of the works in negotiating
mechanisms design look for crucial
mechanisms so these are mechanisms that
we will know in which we incentivize the
bidders to report through valuation
and the reason we do so is the belief
that without certain incentives the
videos are always going to lie if they
can profit from doing so but is it
really the case
research from behavioral economics
suggests that it's not necessarily the
situation
in a very cool experiment
for me as participants to roll a
six-sided die in a cup and reportedly
loads the pair of the participants was
determined as a function of the number
that they reported so the higher the
number the higher the payoff
and only the participants saw the number
that they hold so in principle they
could report any number so always
support six
now what's nice about this experiment is
that even though we cannot tell if a
certain individual lied or not since we
know the distribution of numbers on the
eye on the aggregate we can't tell how
much people like
this example is replicated many many
times on different populations different
variations of the experiments and in
2019 abolitel published a meta-analysis
including 90 papers
and reached the following conclusion
so participants only collect about 25
of the potential gains from lying
we can see this in the following graph
so discussion is taken from a website
accompanying um the
[Music]
company in this meta analysis it
includes the data from experiments that
were running in israel on the x-axis we
have the number reported on the y-axis
the percentage of people reporting it
and different colors correspond to
different experiments
and it's really clear from this picture
that people under report one and two and
the ovary four five and six and they
report five more than six so they don't
lie to the full possible extent
uh some possible explanation for this
include uh first there is some cognitive
cost for lying
and second there is this idea of social
identity which means that we care about
our perceptions by others even strangers
and also our self-perception
and to keep our social identity aligned
with the wall and standards then we're
going to try to refrain from lying as
much as possible
another experiment about applying which
is more related to the setting we're
interested in was run by ougness in o5
and in this experiment we have a pair of
participants a standard and a receiver
and the receiver has to choose one of
the two alternatives either a or b
now only the sender knows the payoff
that they will get for each alternative
so in this case uh if the uh alternative
chosen is one is a sorry standard gets
five the c will get six and if it's b
the center gets six and receiver gets
five
so the sender has this information and
based on this information she decides
which message to send so either the
message option b will earn you more
money than option a
or the opt-in message
and
about 80 of the senders do believe that
the recommendation will be followed
so after the sender made her
recommendation the receiver makes a
choice for example he chose b and payoff
for realized according to the chosen
alternatives
now in all treatments the option that
gives more money to the receiver is
option a so truthful
reporting would mean that the sender
would import a
okay so they check three treatments the
first statement is the one we just
discussed so in this statement payoffs
are symmetric and senders uh don't have
a lot to gain from lying in this case 36
lied
now in the next statement the receiver
can lose quite a lot when the sender lie
and makes it
choose b instead of a so here only 17
lied and the last option is again
symmetric but there is a lot more to
gain from lying
so here more than half of the center
slide
and what we conclude from this
experiment is that when the benefit from
line is smaller than the receivers
then standards tend to lie less
based on these experiments and other
related experiments we conclude two
behavioral assumptions that we are going
to uh based on model
so first individuals have a preference
for tools telling so we can tell the
sound effects experiment that people do
not lie to the full possible extent
and second when deciding whether to lie
or not individuals care about damages to
others how the lies going to affect
others in this paper we refer to people
obeying these two assumptions as moral
bidders and define mechanisms in which
they will
if it's profit from lying is larger than
alpha times the sum of losses of the
other players and alpha here is a
parameter between zero and one so larger
value of alpha implies that the player
is more mobile
more formally the setting we consider is
a single item setting we consider the
domestic mechanisms that are
individually rational and there are no
positive transfers
and here's a formal definition for
mechanism so mechanism is a pair of
functions the location function can
allocate the item to one of the players
or not allocate the item at all and a
payment function
and a mechanism is alpha model if in
every instance v1 to vm for every player
i and vi such that play i has a
possibility to lie and in cases profit
so
this side is uh not easy positive
then
the profit of the player online is at
most alpha times the some flusters of
the other player so please imply that if
the player is small he is not going to
lie in this case
now there are a couple of things to note
about our mechanism so
first of all trussel mechanism is zero
mole so if you take alpha to be zero
here then this simply means that there
is no possible light that a
beta can uh gain form
and second
our assumption for performance for two
stealing appears here in that bidders
measure the gains and losses with
respect to tool styling so this is
considered like the default option
another thing important to note here is
that our players are by no means
altruistic they do want to maximize
their own payoff the only case that they
consider how their actions will affect
other players are when they contemplate
online so when they decide whether to
lie or not they do care about how this
action this line is going to affect
others
and this model is more applicable to
cases in which we can think of readers
that actually know each other so as an
example think of some academic
department
in which the members need to decide how
to allocate some expensive piece of
equipment
so it's probably the case
that one researcher is not going to
exaggerate too much the value of this
equipment
to him if he knows that there's someone
else that really really needs this
equipment
okay
so in this slow we ask what an
auctioneer that only cares about
maximizing its own revenue can take
advantage of the morality of the bidders
in order to increase its own revenue
and to answer this question we provide a
comprehensive analysis of more
mechanisms and the property and the
properties so for example we showed that
the alpha mole mechanisms can sometimes
implement monitoring location functions
with different
pen functions
this is not really helpful for um
getting more revenue since the payment
in this case is always smaller
on the bright side we saw we saw that
the alpha model mechanisms can also
implement nanomolar functions so
functions that cannot be implemented by
two mechanisms
and so
according to this there is some hope uh
and we show that the answer of whether
the actual auctioneer can stack more
revenue or not depends on the valuations
that
on the distribution that the valuations
of the videos are drawn from
so
when you uh we consider
evaluations that are drawn iad from
standard distributions
these distributions include the uniform
distribution exponential distributions
the exact definition is in the paper
then the auctioneer cannot extract more
revenue
and a natural way to go about proving
such a theorem would be to build on
milestone characterization of optimal
auction
so my milestone character is the 10
function in terms of the allocation
function and given this characterization
must prove myosin can completely ignore
the payment function and just continue
to find the location a function
maximizing the revenue now this approach
inherently fails for more mechanisms
since we observed the location function
this when alpha equals one of one mobile
mechanisms is almost unconstrained
so we need to develop all the machinery
required for pulling distilling from
scratch which makes it quite complex
but as a result we also obtain an
alternative proof to milestone
characterization of optimal auctions
when values are done from independent
and regular distributions
when
we complement this result by considering
the case that
the
players evaluations are done from a
quality distribution and show that the
existing player called the distribution
uh for which an alpha model mechanism
can actually extract higher revenue than
any torso mechanism and we also compute
a bound on how much
higher the survey could be
so
that's all
thanks
thank you segal uh there is a question
in the chat by mark uh
so uh mark asks uh i wonder if the
deniability uh that is the probability
for lying condition on the observed
report
plays a role as well and that will
explain people reporting five instead of
six
uh
so
[Music]
i guess i would depend on how you define
this probability of deniability so you
you could say that this probability of
deniability is again related to kind of
like your social identity and how much
you think that someone else might think
you like
because
i mean they roll the die in a cup so
there's no way that
someone else could
i could point out that they are lying
this is just one specific person so this
might have something to do with the
thought process that people have when
they decide not to
understand
if you yeah but somehow i guess if you
try to theorize about others
you would think that people will suspect
you of cheating more if you report to
six
[Music]
it's it's just a different utility
function qualitatively one that it's
it's less about
how likely
will people think the timeline as
opposed to
uh
the intrinsic disability of land
i mean you don't have anything nothing
would happen even if they caught you
lying so it is kind of related again of
how like you you don't want to be the
person that lies
and maybe when you rationalize this
you would say again you might have
a greater choice for getting caught but
like
do you see the point yeah yeah it may no
it makes sense it's just it's uh it's uh
wondering whether this theory has been
explored it's i understand that
as a kind of
it's it's more reasonable to think in in
the terms of actual utilities and not
beliefs
okay great uh so uh
then uh
[Music]
so could you share the screen
can you see my screen
uh yes
cool
uh yeah thanks for the introduction i'm
gonna be talking with all of you about
our paper optimal deterministic clock
auctions and beyond and this is joint
work with your ghost christodoulou and
vasilas gitzeles
but before we get into the results i'll
begin with a brief introduction to clock
auctions in case you haven't seen them
before and even if you aren't interested
in auctions directly i'll explain how to
think about this class of auctions as a
class of algorithms
so imagine that you're working for an
airline and need to allocate the final
seats on a flight you have a set of
families of different sizes each with
the number of seats they require if
they're going to board the flight for
example this green family at the bottom
has four members so they need four seats
and can't be served by any fewer
each of the families uh has a value for
being served and the total social
welfare from serving a set of families
is equal to the sum of the values of the
families in the set
so for example if you served the green
and blue families here um the social
welfare would be 1050.
and since all families have this
non-negative value to maximize the
social welfare you would want to serve
all of the families but of course
there's a feasibility constraint
dictating which you can simultaneously
serve
in this example let's say there are six
seats remaining on the flight then the
maximal feasible sets here would be gray
yellow and blue families green and blue
families and gray and green families
and notably this feasibility constraint
is downward closed so you could also
serve any subset of these maximal sets
and then sort of the natural question is
to maximize the social welfare of the
families we serve subject to this sort
of capacity feasibility constraint
right and this is just the well-known
knapsack problem which is np-hard and
its own right this is already like
non-trivial and interesting but this
isn't really exactly the problem we
study in this work we examine a strict
more challenging problem where the
values are unknown and instead the
private information of the customers and
what if we still want to maximize the
social welfare despite this lack of
information
right so the standard approach that
we've heard quite a bit already in the
field of mechanism design for this kind
of a problem is to run an auction an
auction is simply an algorithm that
decides who should be served in our case
who's going to get the seats on the
plane and at what prices and the most
standard kind of approach is the
so-called sealed bid format
where where the participating customers
each submit a report or bid representing
their value to an auctioneer and the
auctioneer uses these bids to make the
service and price decisions
and then the standard objective is to
design a strategy proof auction which
means the bidders have no incentive to
misreport their true values as their
bids right
and there are indeed many strategy proof
sealed bid auctions proposed in the
literature and mechanism design
but is strategy proofness enough for an
auction to be used in practice
very often it's not
first of all despite strategy proofness
there are still incentive issues here
understanding that an auction is
strategy proof may require parsing a
complicated proof and empirically
bidders do lie even when facing uh
strategy proof options
secondly there are some issues related
to trust since sealed bid auctions
require the bidders to trust that the
auctioneer was following the state
adoption protocol and that the
auctioneer has done all of her
computations correctly
and finally there are privacy concerns
because bidders have to report their
true values directly to the auctioneer
and this could reveal possibly sensitive
um windfall information to the
auctioneer
right so all of these doubts and
questions cast shadow over this format
making it less appealing in many
practical scenarios so we want to know
if we can somehow change the auction
format to address this
and an alternative auction format that's
seen a lot of use in practice is called
a clock auction and in contrast to a
sealed bid auction where the customers
are going to report their costs directly
to the auctioneer in a clock auction
customers face clock prices that weekly
increase over time and they can drop out
whenever the price offer is too high
so to see an example using our plane
ticket scenario let's say the auctioneer
starts with a very low price that she
thinks everyone will accept say a
hundred dollars for all customers
the prices will increase over time and
unlike item pricing which maybe you've
seen in the literature these prices are
not per ticket but rather the cost of
being served so since the green family
is the most restrictive since they need
four seats it probably makes sense to
raise their clock faster than the rest
of the families
and as i mentioned at some point in the
auction the price offered to some
customer is going to become too high in
other words more than their private
value um in this example this is
happening for the yellow family um but
then since prices are weakly increasing
the yellow family can easily verify that
they'll never want to pay for the
service in any future offer and they'll
drop out and permanently exit the
auction
and this will continue possibly causing
more customers to exit um until finally
the remaining set of bidders is feasible
um in this case blue and green can be
served simultaneously so the auction
terminates and they charge their most
recently accepted clock offers 350 for
blue and 550 for green here
so
since clock auctions are more
restrictive in the ways in which we
interact with bidders why would we
actually want to use them in practice
well it's because they address all of
the issues with sealed bid auctions that
we mentioned before
first we have better incentives since
clock auctions offer obvious
strategy-proofness and group
strategy-proofness which are much
stronger incentive notions and strategic
improvements
they also don't require bidders to trust
the auctioneer because they're
transparent and credible which we uh
heard about a little bit earlier
and finally they offer privacy since the
to the winners at least since the
winning customers never reveal their
true value to the auctioneer they reveal
like the smallest amount of information
they could to prove they should win
and while i don't have time to present
them fully all of these notions have
formal theoretical definitions and you
can prove that if you want all of these
properties you need to design a clock
option this combination is unique to
them and finally from an algorithmic
design perspective clock auctions offer
a clear path to designing practical
offers you simply design price
trajectories and this is itself isn't
this itself is an interesting
algorithmic question in each round how
do you decide which prices to increase
and this brings us to our central
question that we study in this work
which is if we look at clock auctions as
approximation algorithms for this social
welfare maximization problem what is the
what are the worst case guarantees we
can achieve
and initial results which studied the
performance of deterministic clock
auctions were very pessimistic
duting it all provided a simple example
with just two disjoint maximal sets
which showed a logarithmic lower bound
in terms of the number of bitters n on
the performance performance of clock
auctions
but then for all we know
complex instances with more than two
maximal sets could show even worse in
approximability
but our main result in this paper is
that the slower bound is tight in
general because we design a
deterministic clock option which we call
the water filling clock auction which
achieves a log n approximation to the
social welfare for any instance with a
downward closed feasibility
and then looking beyond this we take the
first steps toward understanding the use
of randomization clock auctions and
design a randomized clock auction that
breaks through the logarithmic lower
bound for a family of instances that
sort of captures the one providing the
deterministic
so i'll give a slight flavor of how
these two auctions operate
our deterministic auction is called as i
mentioned it's called the water filling
clock auction and it starts as we did in
our plane ticket example with a low
price for everyone say p equals one
and then in each round we look at the
sum of the prices in each maximal set
and choose them to be the current uh
choose the highest sum step to be the
current winners in this case blue offers
a sum of clock prices of four so we mark
them as the winners
and then we just increase the prices of
all the lowest priced bidders outside
this temporarily winning set
and we continue on until exactly one
feasible set remains invaders will drop
out over time as before
and then our randomized option mixes
this water filling approach with
probability one-half with a somewhat
standard sampling approach used
elsewhere in the mechanism design
literature where we sample each bidder
independently with probability one-half
and then use this sampled welfare in
each set as an estimate for the true
welfare that each set offers choosing to
serve the remaining unsampled bidders in
the set of highest sample welfare
and it turns out that the water filling
auction and the sampling auction
complement each other and allow us to
obtain these strongly improved
sub-logarithmic guarantees uh for
families of instances generalizing uh
the deterministic bound
um so in the last few moments i just
want to wrap up with a brief sort of
summary of garment results and a very
fascinating open question
um as i mentioned we give this
deterministic clock auction that is
asymptotically optimal with respect to
the number of bidders for any downward
closed feasibility constraint
we then take a first step towards
understanding the use of randomization
in the design of clock auctions by
proposing a natural way to leverage it
that gives better approximation
guarantees but we leave a really natural
question open
what approximations can be achieved as a
randomized clock auction in general even
for general downward closed settings the
best lower bound we have is a small
constant
so for all we know a randomized clock
auction may indeed give a constant
approximation for any downward flow
setting which would be a sort of like
beautiful result i think if true
yeah and that's all i have so i can take
questions
uh
questions for dan
uh so dan i have a question so there are
actually uh combinatorial clock options
that you know uh people apply for
selling multiple items simultaneously
so
uh like there the incentive uh
properties are much weaker uh but you
know have you guys look into that
uh yeah so so we follow the milgram and
cigals definition which is really only
for single parameter settings so it's
it's exactly as i said it's just you're
served or not it's kind of binary
there's some work in sort of extending
it
beyond that sort i would say like
slightly closer to multi-parameter
but in this work we we solely focus on
single parameter sets at least
i guess my question is more of like do
you think the techniques would you know
apply there uh
um so it's it's hard to say right
because if you have
it's not clear even what you should be
doing i guess if you should have
multiple clocks for each person kind of
representing how much they'll have to
pay for each um set
in which case that seems not so great if
even like simple settings where you're
selling to like a unit demand buyer
right um
because then if you have one one unit
demand buyer and they have a choice of a
bunch of different items
is the only clock auction just to post a
price for each item and let them pick
the best it's it's hard to say right
because if you want these strong
incentive properties um it doesn't
really make sense to kind of raise
prices for each of the items differently
because they'll just drop out
intuitively they might drop out on all
the items that are like not their
favorite um
so it's it's hard to say even like
defining how to get defining the clock
prices and how they should be raising in
these more complicated multi-parameter
settings is i think like even just an
interesting like open area completely
okay
thanks
uh other questions
okay if not then uh
maybe we should just thank all the
speakers of the session again uh
yeah
all right
so uh let's end this session here
nice seeing you all
thanks everyone
you